Нова упаковка зі старих пластикових пляшок? У Німеччині старанно сортують та збирають пластик. Але що відбувається після цього?
Ми простежимо за потоком пластикових відходів, щоб перевірити, чи справді Німеччина є чемпіоном з переробки.
Зрештою, німці вже і так чемпіони, але лише коли йдеться про викидання пластикових відходів.
Для порівняння: у 2016-му житель ФРН спричинив у середньому 38 кілограмів пластикових відходів, тоді як середній показник по ЄС становив 24 кіло.
Це також значно більше, ніж люди викидають в Індії та Індонезії - на 11 та 17 кілограмів відповідно.
Щоб зрозуміти ситуацію, я збираюся стати сміттярем.
А це означає - прокидатися о 5.30 ранку. Також мені потрібно перевдягнутися. У яскраво-помаранчевий.
- Ти мені будеш потрібен цілий день сьогодні.
- Цілий день?! Я не підведу.
Мартін цим займається вже понад два роки. Щодня він пішки долає до 20 кілометрів.
Тож на мене чекає доволі виснажливий день.
Кількість пластикових відходів та упаковки просто вражає.
Тепер я починаю розуміти, що насправді означають 38 кілограмів пластикових відходів на душу населення у Німеччині.
Але проблема не лише у величезній кількості сміття.
Маємо перший недоречний предмет. Тож ми це просто залишимо тут.
Це схоже на метал і точно не на пластик.
За оцінками галузевої асоціації, неправильні відходи містяться у 40-60 відсотках сміттєвих контейнерів.
- Ось коляска, полиця, килим, сушарка.
- Настав час для червоної наліпки!
На ній написано, що це неправильне сортування. Це побутове сміття не належить до пластику. Тож ми його не забираємо.
Ці речі не стають легшими.
Лише дві години на ногах на зміні - а я вже мертвий. А Мартін розповідає мені, що він звик це робити сам.
Неймовірно. Але така кількість сміття - це вже занадто для однієї людини.
Після восьми годин збору пластикових відходів ми повернулися туди, звідки почали.
Я справді не знаю, скільки там того, що ми зібрали.
Час вивантажувати цього "монстра". І це лише одна вантажівка.
У Німеччині, не кажучи вже про решту світу, тисячі таких траків привозять сміття.
- Що в нас вийшло?
- У нас сьогодні понад 5 тонн.
- Понад 5 тонн! Це багато чи мало?
- Це багато.
- Так, я відчуваю по собі, що ми таки багато чого впорали.
Усе сміття, яке я зібрав учора, сортується тут - на одному з найбільших у Німеччині сортувальних заводів.
Це справді гігантське місце. Майже сім тисяч квадратних метрів відведено під сортування пластику.
Тут трохи смердить.
Щодня сюди привозять 400 тонн. Це в 72 рази більше, ніж ми з Мартіном зібрали за день.
Зараз у нас тут значно більше сміття. Це через коронавірус. Ми помітили зміну поведінки споживачів.
У нас на 20 відсотків більше відходів, які потрібно відсортувати.
Через таку кількість пластику більша частина процесу фактично автоматизована.
Сміття сортується за розміром, завдяки магнітам позбуваються металу, а інфрачервоні сканери сортують пластик за вагою.
Але є деякі речі, з якими навіть ця сучасна машина не впорається.
- Що станеться з машиною, якщо я покладу це чи це на конвеєр?
- Два дуже гарні приклади. Це зроблено з термопластику і добре пасує для переробки. Але чорний колір ускладнює роботу машини.
Усі вчать у школі, що чорний колір не відбиває світло. Так і тут. Тим більше, що це транспортується по чорному конвеєру,
і машині складно розпізнати, що це за матеріал.
Друга проблема - ця йогуртова упаковка. Справа в тому, що його різні компоненти фізично не відокремили одне від одного.
- Тож просто розділимо, і їх буде легше переробити.
Ще одна велика проблема - багатошаровий пластик, як ця упаковка сиру.
Тут до 15 шарів, які вже не можна розділити.
Єдине, що можна зробити, - подрібнити та спалити.
Але при цьому виділяється багато токсинів у навколишнє середовище.
Зрештою 60 відсотків побутових пластикових відходів спалюється. Офіційне ж число - 38 відсотків.
Але сюди входить все, що потрапляє на склад для переробки. Навіть відходи, які вивозяться в інші країни.
Німеччина все ще відправляє за кордон понад мільйон тонн пластикових відходів щороку. За цим показником ФРН - третя у світі.
У "Грінпіс" кажуть, що багато країн, куди німці експортують відходи, знаходяться у Південно-Східній Азії.
Але також правда, що не все це потрапляє на сміттєзвалища.
Щоб цього не сталося, деякі компанії створюють нові вироби з переробленого пластику. Ця компанія на півночі Німеччини виготовляє горщики для квітів.
Це доволі рідкісний феномен у Німеччині. Лише близько 16 відсотків усіх пластикових відходів країни перетворюються на нові вироби.
Я думаю, що ми точно є чемпіонами світу зі збору пластикового сміття. І, можливо, воно трохи обробляється.
Але коли справа доходить до перетворення відходів на новий продукт, частка цього у виробництві занадто мала.
Одна з причин - перероблений пластик дорожчий. І коштує до 230 євро більше за тонну, ніж новий пластик.
Крім того, якість знижується від того, чим частіше пластик піддається переробці.
Він стає менш термостійким і легше розривається.
Тож навіть сортуючи і миючи, що вимагає багато енергії, все одно не можна зробити пластик знову на 100 відсотків як новий.
І ринок для товарів з переробленого пластику залишається невеликим. Ця компанія вже три роки цим займається і все ще не має прибутку.
Отже, фраза "Німеччина - чемпіон з переробки" не дуже відповідає дійсності.
Звичайно, у ФРН збирають багато пластику, але лише 16 відсотків насправді перетворюються на нові вироби.
А решта 84 відсотки сміття спалюється або відправляється в інші країни.
Щоб покращити ситуацію, виробники пластику мають полегшити переробку упаковки, зокрема використовувати лише один вид пластику.
А споживачі повинні вирізати пластик скрізь, де це можливо. Або, принаймні, правильно сортувати його.